Now I'm gonna show you the right way to eat sushi, which begins at the sushi bar...
...where you can sit and interact with the chef and ask him what's good to eat.
Once you've found the sushi bar you like, don't order rolls.
Ask for "nigiri", the hand-squeezed rectangles of fish and rice.
That's real sushi.
The chef will serve it to you on a small plate...
...where you can pick it up with your fingers and put it directly in your mouth.
Good sushi should be packed nice and loose...
...so it falls apart on your tongue when you eat it.
The best sushi chefs will season all the sushi for you before they serve it to you.
You don't need to add extra soy sauce or anything else.
Sometimes, a chef might serve it to you without seasoning,...
...in which case, you can dip a corner of sushi in a little bit of sauce.
The ginger is there as a palate cleanser to be eaten between each piece of sushi.
You can eat it with your chopsticks.